well several youth from west las vegas
community were able to have in-depth
conversations with law enforcement today
in a know your rights workshop this
happened at doolittle community center 8
news now reporter victoria saha takes a
look at why these events help build
trust on both sides
the teams and law enforcement i spoke
with say events like this helps them
understand both perspectives if they
were to be approached by law enforcement
so there could be trust coming from both
sides close to 60 youth joined the
conversation at doolittle community
center to understand what to do when
approached by police
twelve-year-old jahi hodge was amongst
them i want to learn how to deactivate a
situation in that when i am with a
police officer as to not you know make
the wrong move or do the wrong action
officer adrian hunt grew up in the area
he says he sees himself in these
participants and wants them to know it's
okay to trust police when i do do the
workshops they say hey does anybody have
family or friends in law enforcement and
i tell them okay what you do now you
know and i give them my email contact
information so if they have any
questions or any you know if they feel
like they've been maybe in a situation
and they're not certain they can reach
out to somebody the event had
explanations of different scenarios and
showed the rights and responsibilities
that the community has when stopped by
police it makes them comfortable as well
and makes them see okay that i can
understand where he's coming from now
one mom joined her daughter in the
workshop she hopes these lessons stick
with her daughter hopefully that she is
aware to just stay calm
to know that she hasn't done anything
wrong and to make sure that she is
obeying what the officer is saying and
we can handle the rest at a later time
if she feels like she is being violated
or anything of that nature a key
takeaway from this event is to let youth
know if they were to encounter police
then they need to just stay calm and
comply running away is not the option in
the newsroom victoria zaha 8 news